zu den Entscheidungen geführt hat
es ging und geht um schwere Vorwürfe
Antisemitismus hat keinen Platz in
Bayern
ist ein Bollwerk gegen Rassismus und
Antisemitismus
das garantiere ich persönlich als
bayerischer Ministerpräsident
da ist das Flugblatt besonders ekelig
widerwärtig
menschenverachtend und absoluter
nazifischer
die Vorwürfe die in dem Zusammenhang mit
diesem Flugplatz im Raum stehen Schaden
Bayern müssen deswegen ernsthaft
bewertet und beantwortet werden
ich habe in den letzten Tagen und vor
allem im letzten Stunden genau abgewogen
mir war dabei wichtig ein faires
geordnetes Verfahren zu finden und nicht
nur nach Medien berichten zu entscheiden
angemessen aufgrund der Vorwürfe aber
auch fair gegenüber der Person wird
avermern und ganz bewusst keine
Vorverurteilung vorzunehmen
da haben wir an Hubert einfach mal 25
Fragen gestellt seine Antworten seine
äußere Öffentlichkeit und ein langes
persönliches Gespräch gestern Abend
sind jetzt die Basis für die Abwägung
Entscheidung
vorab muss man sagen leider war sein
Krisenmanagement der letzten Woche nicht
sehr glücklich
er hätte angesichts des Vorwurfs des
Antisemitismus früher und schlossener
umfassender aufklären müssen
erst alles abzustreiten teilweise Dinge
zuzugestehen manche Widersprüche das hat
die Glaubwürdigkeit in dieser Woche
nicht erhöht spät aus meiner Sicht nicht
zu spät gab es aber eine klare
Entschuldigung und eine klare
Distanzierung es war überfällig aber es
war richtig und notwendig
weil die eigenveraufklärung am Anfang
jedoch zu schleppen war
haben wir 25 Fragen gestellt zu dem
Flugplatz aber auch zu anderen Vorwürfen
aus dieser Zeit
alle Fragen wurden beantwortet
zeitgerecht übermittelt
die Fragen und Antworten werden aus
Gründen der Transparenz im Anschluss
dieses Statements veröffentlicht sowohl
dann die anwesenden Journalisten als
auch im Netz zur Verfügung gestellt es
ist ausdrücklich mit dem Einverständnis
von Hubert einfach nur sogar auf sein
Wunsch hin da passiert oder wird
passieren
zum Inhalt der Fragen die dann auch
jeder noch mal selbst beantworten kann
aber ich sag meine Bewertung
die Antwort waren nicht alle
befriedigend
es war viel Bekanntes wenig Neues
und einiges ist auch nicht innerlich
oder vieles ist nicht der innerlich
zu seinen Gunsten will und muss man
auslegen will ich und muss man auslegen
dass er sich erneut von dem Flugplatz
distanziert hat dass er das bereut
Gefühle möglich ist Gefühle verletzt zu
haben
und in dem sehr langen persönlichen
Gespräch das kann ich ihnen darstellen
hat er mir mehrfach versichert das
Flugblatt sei nicht von ihm
man merkt übrigens sehr und ich habe es
gemerkt wie sehen die ganze Sache
belastet und doch persönlich anfasst
und neu in der Beantwortung der Fragen
ist dass er den Vorfall insgesamt seine
Schulzeit als ein einschneidendes
Erlebnis betrachtet und Zitat dass dies
bei ihm wichtige gedankliche Prozesse
angestoßen hat
nach meiner Bewertung aller vorliegenden
Fakten stellt es für mich am Ende so da
erstens
er hat in seiner Jugend wohl schwere
Fehler gemacht das auch zugestanden
er hat sich dafür zweitens entschuldigt
davon distanziert und auch ruhige Zeit
drittens ein Beweis jedoch dass er das
Flugblatt verfasst oder verbreitet hat
gibt es bis heute nicht
dagegen steht seine ganz klare Erklärung
dass er es nicht war
viertens
seit dem Vorfall von damals gibt es
nichts vergleichbares
fünftens das ganze ist in der Tat 35
Jahre her
kaum einer von uns ist heute noch so wie
er mit 16
daher in der Gesamtabwägung
das kein Beweis vorliegt dass die Sache
35 Jahre her ist das sei dir nichts
Vergleichbares vorgefallen ist wäre eine
Entlassung aus dem Amt
aus meiner Sicht nicht verhältnismäßig
aber einfach Schwamm drüber oder ein
weiter so wäre auch der falsche Weg
natürlich sind viele Gefühle verletzt zu
viel Schaden entstanden und zu viel
Glaubwürdigkeit verloren
daher mein Ernst und gut gemeinter Rat
auch wenn all die Sachen lang her sind
ist es wichtig die Reue und die Demut zu
zeigen
ich finde es ist nicht entscheidend
allein was man mit 16 sagt
sondern wie man als 52-jähriger damit
heute umgeht
und wer ernsthaft bereut der kann auch
leichter auf Verzeihung hoffen
wir haben daher auch gestern Abend nicht
nur persönlich miteinander geredet
sondern hatten auch eine gemeinsame
koalitionsausschüsse
haben intensiv die Situation und die
Zukunft gesprochen
wir waren alle der gemeinsamen
Auffassung das ist wichtig ist dass
Hubert awanger daran arbeitet verloren
gegangenes Vertrauen zurückzugewinnen so
dass er auch Gespräche mit jüdischen
Gemeinden suchen sollte
und vieles zu erklären gemeinsam zu
besprechen es sieht es im übrigen auch
persönlich genauso
wir haben dies auch mit Frau Knobloch
und dann Schuster heute morgen noch
gesprochen
ich weiß meine Entscheidung wird nicht
allen gefallen
bei einigen kleinen Restzweifel
aber ich betone noch einmal das Ergebnis
ist
die Abwägung eines fernen und geordnet
Verfahrens ich empfinde es das Augenmaß
statt Übermaß oder Vorteil
damit steht auch fest werden in Bayern
die bürgerliche Koalition fortsetzen
können
es wird definitiv in Bayern kein
Schwarz-Grün geben und alle Angebote der
Opposition hier so gemacht werden laufen
ins Leere
und wir konzentrieren uns wieder auf das
Wesentliche es gibt nicht um eine Person
in Bayern sondern es geht um andere
große Fragen und Sorgen Mehrzahl der
Menschen hatte Sorgen um die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung in
Deutschland
zum Schluss
das eine unschöne Woche das hat Bayern
gestartet
glauben Sie mir das vielmehr persönlich
alles nicht leicht
ich wollte aber neutral und fair und
doch hat nachhaltig mir dass Situation
umgehen
die Koalition wurde durch die
Berichterstattung um die Freien Wählern
natürlich belastet
ich habe jetzt Ministerpräsident die
Aufgabe Schaden vom Land zu nehmen
Schaden auch zu begrenzen und vor allem
eine stabile Regierung für dieses starke
und wundervolle Land zu gewährleisten
das habe ich nach besten Wissen und
Gewissen getan
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
ich bedauere diese Angelegenheit
damit ist die Sache aber aus meiner
Sicht abgeschlossen meine Entscheidung
steht ich werde den Abgeordneten der
Koalition empfehlen für den kommenden
Donnerstag an Landtag entsprechend mit
dieser Entscheidung zu verfahren
herzlichen Dank und in allen noch einen
schönen Sonntag